veterans are twice as likely as non
veterans to die from accidental
overdoses involving prescription opioids
an effort to lower opioid intake some
veterans are turning to hemp products
like CBD oil to treat chronic pain and
PTSD Nancy Cordes spoke to a group of
veterans lobbying Congress to push the
Department of Veterans Affairs to study
hemp and its potential benefits Nancy
good morning good morning hemp products
like this CBD oil tend to get lumped in
with marijuana because they're both
derived from the cannabis plant but this
won't get you high and unlike some
opioids it won't get you hooked leading
some veterans to say they want more
research and more access I would like to
make very very very clear this is not
marijuana these are not your typical
lobbyists the side effect was to be more
angry more depressed and also seizures
they are veterans whose lives were
nearly ruined first by their injuries
then by their meds I was at a higher
than likely rate of committing suicide
from paint and navy veteran Veronica
Wayne took opioids for 17 years after an
airplane maintenance hatch hit her head
I basically became a walking zombie
she tried medical marijuana but still
felt impaired
that's when she heard about hemp it's
gonna still kill all the pain symptoms
and give you the relief that you need
but you're not gonna feel high now she
uses CBD and oil derived from him but
you can't get it from the VA you can't
get it from the VA it's not it's not
legal like marijuana hemp is derived
from the cannabis plant but it does not
contain THC the chemical that makes you
high still both hemp and marijuana are
classified as schedule 1 controlled
substances restricting the VA and other
federally funded entities from
conducting research the American Legion
is leading the push to change that
anything that makes a veteran feel
better especially something that's
non-toxic is some
we're going to support currently hemp
products are marketed as unregulated
supplements which makes many doctors
reluctant to recommend them
Wayne Jonas is the former director of
the NIH office of alternative medicine
but we're not exactly sure how to use
them what the right dose is how they
interact there are lawmakers on both
sides pushing to change the law I'm
actually cautiously optimistic if we get
something on the floor that it will pass
until then army reservist Dale Ryder
says many of his buddies are weary of
the product that he says helps his back
pain for them they're all worried that
because it's so closely related to
marijuana that could pop up on a drug
test I randomly the cause has a powerful
ally in Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell who hails from Kentucky where
hemp is seen as a potential cash crop
last month he introduced the hemp farm
act of 2018 which would legalize hemp as
an agricultural commodity Nancy thanks
all politics being local